auf jeden fall habe ich dann wirklich
direkt gemerkt alter wenn du hier noch
länger als zehn minuten rum läufst du
bist morgen wieder todkrank also was
geht ab herzlich willkommen beim 1
dieses video keine ahnung ich hoffe ich
schaffe das in einem durch zu lagern
weil ich habe überhaupt keinen bock
irgendwas zu schneiden beziehungsweise
ich will es gar nicht auf die reihe
bekommen auf jeden fall es gibt eine
sache grad direkt mich voll auf also
eigentlich ist das nichts besonderes so
kann jedem mal passieren bzw
jeder ist mal wieder hat wahrscheinlich
an meiner stimme pro krank so geht es
mir gerade irgendwie und das ist eine
sache die mich hoffe ich auf jeden fall
ich hatte ja letzte woche hatte ich
nicht so viele videos gemacht weil ich
keine ahnung ich habe mein abi gehabt
und da hat man erstmal andere als ich
hab mein hobby fertig gemacht hat man
die ergebnisse bekommen dann wird man
natürlich ganz glücklich wenn man das
awi besteht haben wir erstmal ein
bisschen gefeiert und so weiter deswegen
kann man nicht so viele videos habe ich
mir gedacht ja kommen macht einfach
nächste woche ein paar videos und dann
ist mein körper montag eingefallen dass
er erst mal krank wir da dachte ich so
ja ok kommen musst dich aus bis morgen
wieder fit so gestern war es okay aber
nicht wirklich gut also mir ging es
immer noch ziemlich scheiße
und ich habe eigentlich gesagt ab
sonntag kommt sonntag ein video montag
ein video die zacken video mittwoch ein
video donnerstag ein video
gestern habe ich schon nicht geschafft
heute schaffe ich so indirekt aber es
ist ja kein wirkliches video warte ich
muss kurz mal die kammer verwechseln ist
habe ich echt ein
in einem uncut ist es auch egal wird mit
sprachfehler passiert auf jeden fall
genau
ich war dann montag halt krank montag
hatte ich noch ein video produziert habe
dienstag war ich auch krank da habe ich
überhaupt nicht auf die kette bekommen
irgendein video zu drehen so man will
sich dann auch nicht irgendwie dazu
aufraffen wenn man 0 motivation hat
jetzt muss ich wieder danach wechseln
und ja dann war halt jetzt heute
mittwoch und ich dachte gestern morgen
bis zu wieder fit drehst du ein video
wird cool ich habe auch mega viele ideen
so noch im kopf was ich cooles drehen
kann
allerdings jetzt kommt das schlimmer bzw
lustige und zwar ich wollte halt für
heute wirklich wieder fit werden weil
ich habe halt mein abi gehabt oder
geschafft und bei uns ist das dann immer
so halt hier wo ich wohne
man hat an seinem fußballspiel gegen ein
anderes mal andere schule hier wo ich
auf jeden fall mitspielen wollte keine
ahnung das ist nur einmal und scheiß auf
erkältung und so breit morgen ging's
noch recht gut da dachte ich komm du
kannst locker spielen
hoffentlich spielt das wetter mit war
dann leider nicht so
und zwar war das so das war echt genau
heute ist kommst du alles zusammen so
ich hab heut morgen noch gedacht wir
kommen abgeht so war auch ziemlich
motiviert haben uns dann so halt gemacht
und dann fing das spiel an und es hat zu
heftig geregnet und es war immer noch
ein bisschen angeschlagen ich hab dann
direkt gemerkt und ich hab dann wirklich
direkt scheiße jetzt musste ich warten
cut machen weil ich eben gewusst habe
auf jeden fall habe ich dann wirklich
direkt gemerkt alter wenn du hier noch
länger als zehn minuten rum läufst du
bist morgen wieder todkrank also das
heißt todkrank aber halt schon krank so
und das wird immer stärker immer
heftiger mein ganzes meinen ganz mein
ganzer körper war dass ich war so als
wäre ich einfach ins schwimmbad
gesprungen so nass war ich ja und keine
ahnung irgendwann bin ich dann
rausgegangen weil es ging halt gar nicht
mehr klar
und jetzt bin ich gerade zu hause und
mir geht's wieder übels scheiße einfach
so mein hals tut weh mein kopf sitzt du
keine ahnung vielleicht hab ich auch
fieber wer weiß und es regt mich halt
maker auf weil ich einfach ich habe
jetzt halt so in diesem zustand keine
motivation videos zu machen außer dieses
hier was ich jetzt gleich schnell
entscheiden werde
ich hoffe das könnt ihr verstehen
deswegen ja keine ahnung ich denke ich
hoffe einfach morgen geht es mir gut
wenn es mir morgen gut geht kommt morgen
ein video wenn wir morgen nicht gut geht
kommt morgen halt kein video sondern als
freitag oder vielleicht das sonntag ich
kann ziemlich leute tut mir sehr leid
ja ansonsten 20 jahren noch schnell
sagen wollt ihr könnt auch gern mal
unter dieses video schreiben was die
gelder von mir sehen wollt
ja ich hab natürlich selber wie gesagt
dass ziemlich viele ideen aber ich bin
es auch cool wenn man mal vielleicht ein
paar kommentar als ein paar anregungen
für noch mehr videos noch merkt cooles
zeug
ich glaube schon wieder schon wieder
mega viel scheiße das war's für den
video tests durchgefallen hat lässt den
daumen nach oben da wenn es euch
unterhalten hat lasst 2009 spaß ich
gucke einfach so es ist einfach so
richtig als itv also dass ich da
konntest du das einzigste von aziz tv
deswegen will ich mich jetzt auch
komplett wieder auf mein fernseher
konzentrieren schnell ist gleicht er das
video ich wünsche euch allen einen
schönen tag
ich hoffe ihr seid nicht krank drei
leute die euch lieb warum otto